here's the thing
winners think they're losers
and losers always think they're winners
so when's a community comes upstage and
it was like fuck nailed it crushed it
you're like dude that was so like what
how did you turn what i just went that
ted talk how did you just turn that
speech into you killed it that was how
what the fuck happened in your brain
and then we'll kill and then five
specials in a row we have tried to film
me coming off stage afterwards to have
like that moment yeah and you're like
every time i'm like
i i'm like holding my knees i'm like
i'm literally like i'm about to i'm like
we should give everyone refunds to that
like i gotta quit like i feel like i'm
applying to medical school backstage
like no it's like it i'm going we need
to re-shoot that like where i'm gonna
have to reshoot it over student economy
start like and then they show me the
footage like we can't and i'm like
it looks bad it's just like um do you
think it looked but did it really look
bad or that's just your internal i
looked at but i looked like i didn't i
was like yeah i did it
i was like i just remember you coming
off the hbo
i'm your girlfriend and you were
literally like
really yeah it was such a bummer and
then i was like i laughed and you're
like you never laugh at my jokes and i
was like see it was good
well then the director was like what the
fuck
it takes a while i think when you shoot
i think also shooting specials and like
you've cracked this but i think we all
are in a state of like going oh hold on
we do a hundred shows a year
and they're so fun and so great and then
the most important one the one that's
filmed for everyone is the least
energy wise and
i circumstance what we do so it's like
you're playing basketball um on a
cement court
70 games and then the one that matters
the most is on a grass field this is a
totally let me tell you what happened
with mom jeans so i i filmed this in new
york city at the gramercy theater oh
it's such a i love this venue and so the
night before so i'd sold out like four
shows two of which were just like
warm-up
warm-up night and then the next two we
were gonna film so i'm stoked like i
sold them out so fast and like this is
gonna be dope just gonna be fucking lit
bro i bought glitter pants to wear to
the warm-up night i brought like i found
this outfit this crazy outfit and my
opener chase o'donnell we're both just
like high-fiving each other on the way
to the gramercy like oh shit new york
and we get in there and like i i you
know put your ass together and i'm here
like it's okay it's like not electric so
i'm like maybe it's covid i don't know
so i get out there
chase give chasing migraines with your
pants yeah chad did you right i'm such
an asshole so chase does her thing she
comes off she's like yeah they're okay i
go out there and i'm just like
crickets i'm in j why am i in
swimming and hunting tickets yeah and i
get off of my agent's there and i'm like
andrew what the fuck he's like dude
everybody buy tickets nobody came
because of coving it was january and i
was like you got to be shitting me i'm
fucking taping this special and then
when this that did come we're like i'm
going to wear a mask or i'm going to oh
they all had to wear masks for netflix
so then the next day thank god we found
people to fill in blanks and they all
were the fucking you found a bunch of q
and on people you're like we gotta get
the coupons in here anyone think it's a
hoax hey get tim dillon's fans
i don't give a shit we need to get nick
depaulo's
show anybody and then i go out there and
i get on the last speaker and i go
listen to new york i need you to to
fucking show out i bought them all shots
of tequila on both shows before i went
out and i was like get lit it's got to
and they also be wet
a taping they know you're practicing so
i think especially when your fans like
love you they know they like want to be
on their best behavior and they like
they see the camera's flying around and
it's like so like the dream special is
doing a show at you know denver comedy
world i'm just gonna say that club i
love that it's the best like i just like
got chills just thinking about how much
i love that club and um every time i do
that i like makes like i always like
quit comedy uh after i've been on the
road for a while and if i go do that i'm
like i'm back i love this because
i go there whenever i need like uh to
fall in love with comedy
yeah but
if you're
killing at the at the downtown one or
the one out the larimer square one and
then someone's like
we actually just recorded that
that would have been you'd be like that
is how special should be shot
[Music]
four four five
[Music]